[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone mark man and rip
here with playstation competition center
today's topic is the various ways you
can use soul gauge in soul calibur 6.
yeah let's learn the different offensive
and defensive uses for this particular
meter
this curved bar next to your health is
called the soul gauge you build this
gauge largely by attacking although
blocking attacks will still earn you a
small amount
each time you complete the gauge you
earn one stock you can hold up to two
stocks at once
it's worth noting that the reversal
engine mechanic which we cover more
deeply in a separate video
earns a huge amount of meter also when
your opponent is one round away from
winning you will get an entire stock of
meter for free
there are three primary ways sole gauge
is spent until caliber six and each use
costs a full stock
meter the first is a defensive option
called soul charge
to activate soul charge you simply hold
back and press r2 or all three attacks
your character will emit a burst of
energy and your soul gauge will begin
ticking down
when this timer reaches the bottom
you'll exit the soul charge mode
when you're install charge all of your
attacks do a small amount of damage even
when they're guarded
but beyond that soul park powers up each
character in completely different ways
for most certain attacks become enhanced
they may gain new properties like break
attacks
do more damage or combo in different
ways several characters will even gain
access to entirely new moves and stances
which can drastically change how they
play to learn more about your favorite
character and how they benefit from soul
cards
access the combat lessons option from
the training mode
and then choose soul charging if you do
a quarter circle forward motion and
press r2 you'll perform with soul attack
which leaves you in soul charge mode
after why pick one method over the other
well the energy burst method is very
defensive you'll push the opponent away
and be
completely safe and counter attack
whether they guarded the burst or not
use this if you're being pressured and
need a safe way to gain some space
the attack on the other hand is very
offensive soul attacks are risky used by
themselves and are easily dodged
but you can combo into them and they'll
keep your opponent close so you can
continue your offense with your sole
charge abilities
the other primary way to spend sole
gauges called critical aim simply press
r2 to activate a highly damaging super
attack
for your character
you can use critical edge attacks and
some combos to add extra damage or
if your opponent misses an attack right
next to you you can use the critical
edge to punish them for their mistake
as a final note there's a way to spend
50 of your soul gauge on a pairing
mechanic called resist impact
we covered that in our video on garden
packs we want to learn more about it
while critical edge may be flashy and
cool as a beginner you might want to opt
going for the defensive option
soul charge instead as it can get you
out of some tricky situations
that's all for this episode this
tutorial is made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can sign up for open series
competitions on compete.playstation.com
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials and soul calibur 6
content